DNA robots just got a remote control
this microscopic robotic arm is
self-assembled and made a folded DNA
it's a kind of DNA origami which has
been used to build many things on the
nano scale minuscule letters teddy bears
even the Mona Lisa now researchers have
shown the ability to remotely control a
nano scale DNA device the robot arm
rises up out of a flat DNA platform on a
glass slide while the arm is made out of
relatively rigid DNA helixes bundled
together it's attached by flexible
single-stranded DNA pieces that allow it
to rotate the technique relies on the
negatively charged nature of DNA
the researchers applied a charge to the
system to move the arm around and
tracked its position using fluorescent
signals picked up by microscopy the
movement happens within milliseconds 1
million fold faster than previous
examples in DNA nanotechnology in some
experiments the arms movement was
stopped short by DNA strands sticking up
perpendicularly from the platform the
arm could only move if the charge was
driving it to let go of these
complementary strands and then only to
set positions this shows that the DNA
arm can move like a latch between
predefined configurations under remote
control if combined with cargo transfer
techniques these tiny DNA robot arms
could be used to remotely pick up and
drop off molecular components opening
the door to true 3d printing of
molecules
[Music]
you